الى اسدود وعسقلان وبئر السبع وهرت سيليا
وتانيا فالقدس المحتله وصولا الى تل ابيل
والى موقع صوفا العسكري وكرم ابو سالم
وناح العوز وارز ونتف عسره وغلاف غزه الى
قاعده حتسور الجويه وحد سريم وتل نوف وصل
مدى صواريخ
[موسيقى]
المقاومه قام فريق التحقيق بعمل تحليل
رقمي رصدنا من خلاله حجم التطور لمدى
صواريخ المقاومه التي اطلق اولها عام 2001
بمدى يصل الى ثلاثه كيلومترات وبعد نحو 20
سنه وفي المواجهه الاخيره تحديدا قصفت
اسرائيل بصاروخ اس اتش 85 والذي بلغ مداه
نحو و85 كت وبصاره بدر ثلاثه وبلغ مداه
نحو 160 كترا اما ابعدها مدى فكان صاروخ
عياش
250 والذي تجاوز مداه 250 كيلومترا نن
عندما نتحدث عن الصواريخ التي استخدمناها
نتحدث عن الاجيال السابقه اتحدث عن صاروخ
صواريخ القدس محليه الصنع كذلك نتحدث عن
الاجيال المعاصره التي انتجت وحده
الصناعات العسكريه ووحده الانتاج الحربي
في صرايا القدس وانا اؤكد لكم ان هناك
صواريخ لم تدخل الخدمه بعد ما رايناه من
تقدم في تكنولوجيا الصواريخ لدى مقاتلي
غزه يتمثل في ان بامكانهم توسيع المدى
وتحميل رؤوس حربيه اضخم قادره على الحاك
اضرار
اكثر هذه الموجودات تمنح فصائل غزه قدره
ضاربه تحقق عددا من الاشياء فهي تعقد مهمه
المدافع من خلال زياده المساحه المطلوب
الدفاع عنها ولكنها ايضا تعرض للتهديد
اهدافا اكثر اهميه من الناحيه السياسيه
مثل تل
[موسيقى]
ابيب هذه ضربات صاروخيه منكل الاتجاهات
الان
[موسيقى]
سنائي
وفق صحيفه ذا جيروسالم بوست الاسرائيليه
فان تكلفه صواريخ القبه الحديديه اكثر
بكثير من تكلفه تصنيع الصواريخ الفلسطينيه
التي تسقطها ما يضيف عامل النزيف المالي
المستمر لابقاء منظومه القبه الحديديه في
الخدمه الصاروخ الفلسطيني لا يقدر بثمن
ابدا فنحن عندما نتحدث عن الصاروخ
الفلسطيني
نتحدث عن صاروخ صنع من وسط الحصار ونتحدث
عن صاروخ ربض وسط تحليق مكثف لطيران
الاستطلاع نتحدث عن صاروخ اطلق وسط تحليق
مكثف لهذه الطائرات ووسط المراقبه الجويه
والبحريه والبريه من قبل
[موسيقى]
العدو